La compasión.
¿Qué aspecto tiene?
Acompáñenme al 915 de South Bloodworth Street
en Raleigh, Carolina del Norte, donde me crié.
Si entran nos verán, por las noches,
sentados a una mesa puesta para diez personas, pero no siempre todas las sillas están ocupadas.
En el momento en que estaban a punto de servir la cena,
dado que mi madre tenía ocho hijos,
a veces decía que se le hacía difícil distinguir quién era quién y donde estábamos.
Antes de empezar a comer, ella preguntaba:
¿Están todos los niños?
Y si faltaba alguien,
debíamos preparar un plato para esa persona, ponerlo en el horno,
luego bendecíamos la mesa, y entonces podíamos comer.
También, mientras estábamos sentados a la mesa,
existía un ritual en nuestra familia.
Cuando le sucedía algo importante a alguno de nosotros,
ya fuera que a mi madre la hubiesen elegido Presidenta de la Asociación de Padres y Profesores,
o que a mi padre le hubiesen asignado un trabajo en la universidad,
o que alguien hubiese ganado un concurso de talento,
el ritual familiar consistía en que tras anunciar el acontecimiento,
debíamos dedicar cinco o diez minutos a lo que llamábamos "hacer aspavientos",
es decir, felicitar ruidosamente a la persona que de alguna manera había sido honrada,
ya que cuando se honra a una, nos honramos todos.
También teníamos que informar a cada miembro de nuestra extensa familia,
es decir, a miembros de la familia
que estaban enfermos, eran ancianos y no podían salir.
Mi tarea consistía en, al menos una vez por semana, visitar a la Madre Lassiter,
que vivía en East Street,
a la Madre Williamson que vivía en Bledsoe Avenue,
a la Madre Lathers que vivía en Oberlin Road.
¿Por qué? Porque eran ancianas y estaban enfermas.
Y debíamos ir a verlas por si necesitaban algo.
Mi madre decía, "Ser familia es querer, compartir y cuidarnos los unos a los otros.
Ellos son nuestra familia".
Y claro, a veces recibíamos un premio por hacerlo.
Nos ofrecían dulces o dinero.
Mi madre decía: "Si les preguntan cuánto cuesta que ustedes les hagan las compras,
siempre respondan: Nada.
Y si insisten, digan: "Lo que usted quiera darme".
Ese era el sentido de nuestra presencia en aquella mesa.
De hecho, ella nos decía que si hacíamos eso,
no sólo tendríamos la alegría de recibir el agradecimiento
de parte de nuestros familiares,
sino que también, como decía, "Hasta el Señor sonreirá, y cuando el Señor sonríe
hay paz, justicia y alegría".
Así es como en la mesa del 915 aprendí algo sobre la compasión.
Obviamente, éramos una familia de pastores,
así es que teníamos que tener presente a Dios.
De ese modo llegué a pensar que la madre eterna
siempre se está preguntando: "¿Estarán todos los niños en casa?"
Y si habíamos sido nobles ofreciendo cariño y generosidad,
sentíamos que la justicia y la paz tendrían una oportunidad en el mundo.
Pero no todo era maravilloso en aquella mesa.
Permítanme explicarles una situación en la que no festejamos.
Era el día de Navidad, y en nuestra familia, ¡oh qué mañana!
La mañana de Navidad, cuando abríamos nuestros regalos,
rezábamos oraciones especiales, nos sentábamos al piano
y cantábamos villancicos. Era un momento muy íntimo.
De hecho, uno podía acercarse al árbol a buscar sus regalos, prepararse para cantar
y luego prepararse para el desayuno sin siquiera darse un baño o vestirse,
pero papá lo arruinó todo.
Una persona que trabajaba con él no tenía dónde celebrar
la Navidad de ese día en particular.
Y papá trajo al hermano Revels a nuestro festejo familiar de Navidad.
Todos pensamos que estaba desquiciado.
Este es nuestro momento de intimidad.
Aquí es donde podemos mostrarnos tal cual somos,
y ahora tenemos a este hombre todo vestido
con camisa y corbata, y nosotros aún en pijama.
¿Por qué traería papá al hermano Revels?
En cualquier otro momento, ¡pero no en Navidad!
Y mamá nos escuchó y dijo:
"¿Pues saben qué? Si realmente entienden el significado de esta celebración,
es un momento en el que ampliamos nuestro círculo de amor.
De eso se trata esta celebración.
Es el momento de hacer espacio, de compartir la felicidad de la vida en una comunidad de amor".
Así que nos callamos.
(Risas)
Pero en el 915 la compasión no era una palabra para debatir,
era el sentimiento de cómo somos juntos.
Somos hermanas y hermanos unidos.
Y, como dijo el Jefe Seattle, "Nosotros no tejemos la telaraña de la vida.
Somos sus filamentos.
Y cualquier cosa que hagamos a la telaraña, nos la hacemos a nosotros".
Eso es compasión.
Entonces. permítanme decirles que veo al mundo así.
Veo imágenes, y algo me dice "Eso es compasión".
Un campo cosechado con algo de grano en las esquinas
que me recuerda la tradición hebrea,
que tú puedes recoger la cosecha,
pero debes dejar siempre algo en los bordes
para que alguien que no tenga
obtenga lo necesario para una buena nutrición.
Hablemos de una imagen de compasión.
Veo... siempre me remueve el corazón
una foto del Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
caminando cogido del brazo con Andy Young, el Rabino Heschel
y tal vez Thich Nhat Hanh, y algunos otros santos reunidos,
cruzando el puente y yendo a Selma.
Sólo una foto.
Cogidos del brazo por la lucha.
Sufriendo juntos en la esperanza común de que podemos ser hermanos y hermanas.
sin los accidentes de nuestro lugar de nacimiento o etnia
que nos roban el sentimiento de "unidad del ser".
Aquí tenemos otra imagen. Aquí, esta. Me gusta mucho esta imagen.
Cuando el Dr. Martin Luther King Jr. fue asesinado,
ese día, todos en mi comunidad estaban dolidos.
Ustedes escucharon sobre disturbios por todo el territorio.
Bobby Kennedy debía dar un mensaje en Indianápolis.
Este es el cuadro. Le dijeron:
"Vas a estar en una situación muy volátil".
Él insistió: "Debo ir".
Estaban sentados en su camión
los mayores de la comunidad
y Bobby se puso de pie y le dijo a la gente
"Tengo malas noticias para ustedes.
Alguno de ustedes puede no haber escuchado que el Dr. King ha sido asesinado.
Sé que están enojados,
y sé que casi desearían tener la oportunidad
de entrar en actitudes de venganza, pero
quiero que ustedes sepan que yo sé cómo se sienten.
Porque alguien muy querido por mí me fue arrebatado.
Sé cómo se sienten.
Espero que ustedes tengan la fuerza para hacer lo que yo hice.
Permití que mi enojo, mi amargura, mi dolor estuviesen ahí por un tiempo,
y luego tomé la decisión de que yo iba a hacer un mundo diferente,
y podemos hacer eso juntos".
Esa es una imagen. ¿Compasión? Creo que la veo.
La vi cuando el Dalai Lama vino a la Iglesia de Riverside cuando yo era un pastor,
y él invitó a representantes de todas las tradiciones de fe de todo el mundo.
Les pidió que dieran un mensaje.
Y cada uno leyó en su propio idioma una afirmación central,
y esta fue una versión de la regla de oro.
"Haz a los demás lo que quieres
que te hagan a ti".
12 en sus trajes eclesiásticos, culturales o tribales
afirmando un mensaje.
Estamos tan conectados que debemos tratar a todos
como si una acción hacia ti fuese una acción hacia mí mísmo.
Una imagen más mientras pienso en la Iglesia de Riverside.
9/11. Última noche en las cataratas de Chagrin,
un reportero y comentarista de televisión dijo
esa noche, cuando trasladamos el servicio religioso de Riverside
a la estación de nuestra ciudad:
"Fue uno de los momentos más poderosos de nuestras vidas.
Todos estábamos sufriendo,
pero usted invitó a representantes de todas las tradiciones,
usted los invitó.
Averigüe qué dice su tradición,
qué debemos hacer cuando hemos sido humillados,
cuando hemos sido despreciados y rechazados".
Y cada uno habló de su tradición,
unas palabras sobre el poder sanador de ser solidarios unos con otros.
Ahora bien, yo desarrollé un sentido de compasión de una segunda naturaleza.
Pero me convertí en predicador.
Ahora, como predicador, tengo un trabajo. Tengo que predicar,
pero es un deber también.
O, como el Padre Divine solía decir a sus feligreses en Harlem,
"Algunas personas predican el Evangelio.
Yo debo hacer tangible el Evangelio".
Entonces, la cuestión central es: ¿Cómo hago tangible la compasión?
¿Cómo la hago real?
Mi fe ha elevado este ideal constantemente
y me ha desafiado cuando he caído por debajo de él.
En mi tradición, hay un regalo que hemos dado a otras tradiciones.
Todo el mundo conoce la Parábola del Buen Samaritano.
Mucha gente piensa en ella principalmente en términos de caridad,
de actos de bondad al azar.
Pero para aquellos que estudian los textos con un poco más de profundidad,
descubrirán que ha surgido una pregunta
que apunta a esta parábola.
La pregunta era: "¿Cuál es el mandamiento más grande?"
Y Jesús nos lo dice
"Deben amarse a ustedes mismos,
deben amar al Señor nuestro Dios con todo su corazón, mente y alma,
y a su vecino como a ustedes mismos".
Y esa persona preguntó, "Bien, ¿qué quieres decir con vecino?
y él le contestó contando la historia del hombre que cae entre ladrones.
De cómo las autoridades religiosas fueron hacia otro lado,
y cómo los feligreses en la congregación fueron hacia otro lado,
pero una persona inesperada, despreciada, se acercó,
vio al necesitado,
le dio aceite y vino para sus heridas,
lo puso en su transporte,
lo llevó a la posada
y le pidió al posadero, "Cuídalo.
Aquí tienes, esta es la paga inicial
pero si las necesidades continúan, asegúrate de satisfacerlas.
Y cualquier otra necesidad que surja, yo se la cubriré y pagaré por ello a mi regreso.
Esto siempre me ha parecido que profundiza
en el sentido del significado de lo que es ser un buen samaritano.
Un buen samaritano no es simplemente alguien que se ha conmovido
en un acto inmediato de asistencia y caridad,
sino alguien que provee un sistema de asistencia sostenible, eso me gusta,
un sistema de asistencia sostenible en la posada.
Creo que es el momento de la Biblia en el que se menciona un sistema sanitario.
y un compromiso de hacer lo que haga falta
para que todos los niños de Dios tengan sus necesidades cubiertas,
para que podamos contestar a la eterna pregunta materna:
¿La salud llega a todos los niños?". Y que podamos decir que sí.
Qué felicidad ha sido para alguien que busca tangibilizar la compasión.
Les recuerdo que mi trabajo como pastor
ha incluido siempre ocuparme de las necesidades espirituales
relacionadas con la vivienda y la salud
de los presos, los enfermos, los niños,
incluso los niños en acogida por quienes no puedes siquiera mantener un registro
de dónde comenzaron, hacia dónde van.
Ser un pastor es cuidar de estos intereses individuales.
Pero ahora, ser un buen samaritano, siempre lo digo,
y ser un buen americano, para mí,
no es felicitarme por actos individuales de asistencia,
la compasión tiene una dinámica corporativa.
Creo que eso que hacíamos en la mesa en Bloodworth Street
debe hacerse en las mesas y los rituales de fe
hasta que nos convirtamos en esa familia, esa familia unida,
que comprende la naturaleza de la unidad.
Somos una persona unida.
Entonces, déjenme explicarles lo que entiendo por compasión,
y por qué creo que es tan importante que en este momento de la historia
decidamos establecer esta carta por la compasión.
Es importante porque este es un momento muy especial en la historia.
Es un momento en el que, bíblicamente, podríamos decir
que es el día, o el año del favor de Dios.
Es una etapa de gracia.
Están comenzando a ocurrir eventos inusuales.
Por favor, perdónenme, como hombre negro, por celebrar
que la elección de Obama fue una señal inusual
del hecho de que este es un año de favores,
y aún hay tanto más por hacer.
Necesitamos traer salud, alimentos, educación
y respeto por todos los ciudadanos de Dios, todos los niños de Dios,
recordando a la madre eterna.
Y permítanme acabar mis comentarios contándoles
que cuando siento algo muy profundamente,
normalmente toma la forma de un verso.
Y por eso quiero concluir con una pequeña canción.
Con esta canción, una canción infantil,
porque todos somos niños sentados a la mesa de la madre eterna.
Y si la madre eterna nos ha enseñado correctamente,
esta canción tendrá sentido, no solo para quienes son parte de esta reunión,
sino para todos los que firman la carta por la compasión.
Y por esto lo hacemos.